bah bah but I'm pum pum pum pum pum pum
pum mom good morning belief nation
today's message is trust your instincts
over to you Tina Fey I've learned to and
continue to try to learn to trust my own
instincts when it comes to writing and
also producing sometimes the only times
I have regret about something we've done
is if I if I didn't kind of follow my
instinct to at least ask a question
about a story point or something we were
doing so what do you think I think it
was a really short clip but there was so
much there and maybe I'm reading more
into what she's saying you know from my
own experience but like her the time
where I'm like oh gosh I wish I hadn't
done that is when i second-guessed
myself it's when i listen to other
peoples when i made an effort to try and
be more politically correct so to speak
you know i'm gonna try and i'm gonna try
and consider more candidates even though
i found a candidate for employment that
I really think is great I'm gonna try
and be more open to listen to everyone's
feedback even though in my heart I've
already made up my mind on what I want
to do and then it waters down what would
I know to be correct only because when
you're making a decision when you're
running a business when you're hiring
people when you're marketing when you're
doing anything it's an expression of you
people are buying into who you are as
the owner is the brand and every time
you take in all those other things
you're just watering down who you really
are who you really are people are going
to love or they're going to hate and
that's fine but if you just water it
down with all these other things you're
not trusting your instincts man it's
just the times that I regret or when I'm
listening to other people even though I
know what what I should do for me I
think it's about when you have those
crazy ideas to do something about it as
entrepreneurs we come up with the crazy
ideas right like I don't want to try
this and then the next one you wake up
and you don't have the courage anymore
to do it because of whatever you don't
believe you have the skills or
capabilities or you're worried but what
people going to think about you've come
all these reasons why you can't go and
do it and more and more and more when I
come with a crazy idea
I just do it just the next morning wake
up and find a way to do it i was up till
three in the morning last night thinking
about toronto day and salsa and thinking
about families are one word and thinking
about what smell is family and I walked
in here asking these guys what his
family smell like cinnamon and apples
right you ask that question to most
people in the book are you crazy like
you're a salsa school what does have to
do with cinnamon and apples but it's
relevant and it's important it's
something I want to test out and try
maybe it doesn't work but more often
than not it does work even though the
people around you think that might be
crazy and so trust your instincts for me
is when you have those crazy ideas you
owe it to yourself to go out and just
try it because you don't want to live
with regret then like a year later
thinking I really wish gave it my shot
and I share some stories how about you
okay ya know you can cut this over no
I'll keep it keep it okay so I remember
a few years ago Evan Evan came to our
mastermind group and he said that he
wanted to create entrepreneur trading
cards and and you came to the group and
you said I want to create a baseball
card a famous entrepreneurs and I was
like that is crazy that is ridiculous
why would you spend money and time on it
why would you do this and you know today
he called me the little man and that's
fine but but I remember the time
thinking why like this makes no sense
and you proceeded with it you went
through with it it's it's like one of
the coolest things I've seen someone do
because it makes it makes no sense in my
very kind of logical rational mind why
any of that stuff would connect but Evan
didn't listen to me you didn't listen to
the other people who questioned why it
would happen and you just ran ahead with
it and you found like baseball card
companies and you've got licenses for
artwork and you you lined up like all
these cool people and it became one of
the things that I'm like most proud of
you doing which was a total passion play
which had nothing to do with business at
all and I learned from that that that
like Evans tenacity to just be like I'm
doing this and then run off and do it
I've learned from that and and
personally I work to try and instill a
little bit of that myself
that was a fun project and and you know
the business side of it put me on the
radar of Tony Hsieh from zappos and Tim
Ferriss and Seth Godin mike arrington a
bunch of big power players in business
and we raised over a hundred thousand
dollars for for charity all the proceeds
of those cards went to charity for
entrepreneurs in Africa getting started
and so that he'll freeze we just crossed
over into those now so it's pretty cool
okay that all makes sense now but years
ago I did not I did not see it right
then you know what like to the point I
didn't know either right like it's
always hindsight is always twenty-twenty
I can look back and say all the benefits
that I got from it but when I got into
it I said I'm gonna do this crazy thing
and create entrepreneur trading cards
and I don't care who doesn't like it I'm
just gonna gonna do it and trust that
it's gonna work out that's just my
mantra now is just you have a crazy idea
you're going to try it out what do you
do when everyone around you thinks that
you're crazy idea is crazy and when your
instincts have have let you down in the
past what do you do they almost never I
don't know like so first of all I'm used
to having everybody around me think that
I'm crazy for for Toronto dance also
from my business I'm the crazy one I
don't even know the half of it hahaha
I'm the crazy orange and and I'm used to
the weird looks and I'm used to the like
that makes no sense for our business I'm
used to that we're going to lose money
on this I think part of being the boss
is I get to decide what I do and and I
never force people to come along is like
I'm an army of one I will will this into
existence I will do this myself it's
going to happen I'm gonna make it happen
come on board if you want if not cool
I'm going to make it happen regardless
because I don't I hate pulling people a
long time who don't want to be they
don't believe who have to be like
convinced to do it what do you do if
you're at a point your career where
you've tried a few things and they just
didn't go well and you're lacking that
confidence that's what I mean when when
you believe so strongly in something and
it's your fourth you know idea or it's
your fifth business and everything kind
of just went this way and everyone's
like you're crazy how do you push
through I think I mean I maybe though
I'm going to be the crazy one I may be
the wild card or maybe
not enough of a pragmatist I think for
me I have a really short memory like I'm
a I'm an optimist if something goes
wrong I learned from it and I see that
as a positive experience not like oh I
failed so I'm going to feel that
everything else I'm never going to take
my shot again I tried it it didn't work
so I pivot and do something else like
the cards we're great and then and then
I grew tired of making them and so I
stopped like I haven't done a second run
like that could have been like 10 series
I just moved on to something else like I
know I'm used to trying a lot of
different stuff and not it have
everything stick fail fast i guess i
don't i guess like will try million
different things on the youtube channel
we've tried a lot of different series
some of them i like some of them like at
a time and then we rotate and shifted it
out and done other things my channels
evolved if you go back and look at the
channel from the start to where it is
now than a lot of different things but i
don't see those other videos as failures
i learned through it I got better and
I'm excited about the next thing like
there's always the next thing next i'm
addicted to growth and innovation and
crazy ideas I need to always have
something crazy going on for me to feel
fulfilled and and that I'm having an
impact and so I'm used to the I'm used
to the crazy faces and looks I think
once you show that like you can get
through it then then you like I'm used
to it so I don't care like your opinion
like have you done what I want to do
nosso your opinion is meaningless to me
so I'm going to go and do it and move on
I love it I love it longest and digress
whoever got give you so fired up so the
question of the day today is of this
ranch what was your favorite part you're
part of the ranch leave in the comments
will join the discussion thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso okay
nespresso TV go